the Biden Administration has decided to
send cluster bonds to Ukraine what are
cluster bonds a lot of people don't know
what it is and the moment that any novel
or somewhat obscure concept hits the
headlines all of a sudden everybody's an
expert on it they're all armchair
experts who you know attended naval war
college or something like that cluster
bombs are a particularly dangerous type
of munition
that will will blanket a space with with
explosives that have a fairly High fail
rate and so what that means is if you
drop a bunch of cluster Munitions all
over the countryside a lot of them might
not go off and so even years after the
close of a conflict you have a lot of
civilians and farmers and travelers
getting blown up by these kinds of
Munitions this is why Jen Saki last year
as White House Press Secretary
suggested that cluster bombs might
constitute a war crime there are reports
of illegal cluster bombs and vacuum
bombs being used by the Russians if
that's true what is the next step of
this Administration and is there a red
line for how much violence will be
tolerated against civilians in this
manner that's illegal and potentially
War crime it is it would be I don't have
any confirmation of that we have seen
the reports uh if if that were true it
would potentially be a war crime
obviously there are a range of
international fora that would assess
that
um so certainly we would look to that to
be a part of that conversation
so cluster bombs
intrinsically
might constitute a war crime
and when jensaki was asked about that it
was in the context the hypothetical of
Russia using cluster bombs
oh yes that might very well be a war
crime
now we are sending cluster bombs to
Ukraine that's not that's not either Joe
Biden is admitting that he's a war
criminal
or we're saying no no when we do it it's
not a war crime
and the the most honest liberals the
most honest proponents of the war in
Ukraine are going to make that argument
they're going to say it's a war crime
when Russia does this type of thing but
it's not a war crime when America does
this type of thing and it's probably
going to be a difficult argument to make
but maybe somebody can make it
we need that kind of clarity
this has been a major shift in politics
in my lifetime
it's been a Reckoning with American
foreign policy that was pretty much on
autopilot since World War II
finally now people on the left and on
the right are beginning to look at it a
little bit more consciously Donald Trump
did a lot of that Donald Trump was the
first Republican
first major Republican presidential
candidate in my lifetime who said the
war in Iraq was a bad idea
now you might defend George Bush in the
war in Iraq you might say well he didn't
know the our intelligence told us that
that Saddam Hussein was producing
weapons of mass destruction the
intelligence Community got it wrong this
that or the other thing you might say it
was it was the right decision to be made
at the time albeit perhaps on bad
information some people I mean some of
the real hardcore neocons will still
defend it even with the bad information
but
when you when you look at the war in
Iraq
it was the United States aggressing
right we invaded a country
based on what turned out to be a mostly
false pretext
when you look at Libya the invasion of
Libya
with the sport of NATO in Iraq and in
we just invaded a country because we
didn't like what they were doing Libya
wasn't threatening the United States
Libya wasn't threatening NATO Nations
this wasn't an article 5 Invasion we
just went in because we didn't like the
guy we invaded that country
now fast forward to the war in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin's justification for
invading Ukraine was that Ukraine is
cozying up to Nato Ukraine wants to join
NATO NATO is going to let them in by the
way that's happening now there's a major
push to let Ukraine into NATO
and there's major push to let Ukraine
into European union and all the rest of
it
and Putin said we can't tolerate this we
can't have NATO right up on our border
especially in the breadbasket of Europe
Ukraine because NATO is an aggressive
organization that seeks to harm Russia's
national interest
now all the NATO supporters said well
that's not true NATO is a defensive
Alliance we're only here to defend
ourselves we would never start a war we
would never aggress we would never
invade without a sufficient predicate
for invasion
and then Vladimir Putin can point to
Libya and then Vladimir Putin can point
to Iraq flight report to Kuwait Vladimir
Putin complaint which all sorts of
places and say or Kosovo rather and say
uh no you guys have been aggressors you
guys have been a little more active than
you're pretending
to have been
and NATO doesn't have very much to say
about that
it's a healthy thing to ask every once
in a while are we the Baddies
I don't think necessarily we are you've
got to have that healthy sense and this
is why by the way the Trump side of the
GOP
scored this is why Barack Obama beat
Hillary Clinton because Barack Obama
opposed the war in Iraq Hillary still
defended the war in Iraq
there is a a major not just left or
right it's a populist
movement that is reconsidering American
foreign policy and so you've got the
many people who are opposed to foreign
adventurism
versus the elite who have a lot more
political influence than the many this
is why Tucker Carlson who's the most
prominent member was until he got fired
was the most prominent populist on cable
television and they fired him probably
because he was a little too populist
he's the most popular guy in the history
of cable news
he was the one articulating this view
maybe we shouldn't be engaging in so
much foreign adventurism
if you liked the sound of that you are
going to love the taste of magic spoon
even more with magic spoon you can say
goodbye to Bland sugary cereals and
experience breakfast like never before
packed with high quality ingredients and
flavors that you already know and love
like cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter which is very very tasty magic
spoon will take your breakfast game to
new heights my producer Ben Davies can't
stop talking about how much he loves
magic spoons peanut butter cereal
to which I say hey you jerk stop
stealing the peanut butter cereal from
the office and let me have it instead
but he loves it he really likes it so I
figure I'll throw the guy a bone he can
have the box of peanut butter I'll save
myself for the other magic spoon cereals
have zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and are only 140 calories per
serving they're also gluten-free grain
free and soy free experience the magic
of magic spoon cereals by visiting
magicspoon.com Knowles and get five
bucks off your order Magic spoon is so
confident in their product they back it
with a 100 happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money what are you waiting
for click the link below or head over to
magicspoon.com Knowles to grab a variety
pack try it today magicspoon.com for
five bucks off your order
major pop culture story that I am being
forced to know about
because that's how social media work I
would not
I barely know who Jonah Hill is
I did not know that Jonah Hill and Seth
Rogen were different people until about
three years ago
and I've just they're different people
now Seth Rogen is a huge lib Jonah Hill
I assume is a big lib too but
I actually think based on the leaked
text messages they're creating a huge
Hollywood Tempest in a teapot
Jonah Hill might be one of the most
normal people in Hollywood
what came out was a series of private
text messages leaked by Jonah Hill's
ex-girlfriend portraying him as an
emotionally abusive monster
this after Jonah Hill announces that
he's had a baby with his girlfriend so
he's not married he should marry his
girlfriend uh they've just had a baby
and this ex-girlfriend of something like
two years ago releases text messages and
this is what she says is an example of
emotional abuse
Jonah texts her and says quote
plain and simple if you need surfing
with men boundaryless inappropriate
friendships with men to model to post
pictures of yourself in a bathing suit
to post sexual pictures friendships with
women who are in unstable places and
from your wild recent past Beyond
getting a lunch or coffee or something
respectful I'm not the right partner for
you if these things bring you to a place
of happiness I support it and there will
be no hard feelings these are my
boundaries for romantic partnership my
boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust
that's it
that's the that's the the example of an
emotionally abusive this is one of the
most mature
romantic treatises I've read in our
entire popular media it's not perfect I
don't like the idea of talking about
romance as a partnership we're just
we're in a partnership and I don't I
don't like the idea of divorcing romance
from the end of marriage and children
all the rest of it but what he's saying
here is yeah look if you wanna
if you want to have boundary less
inappropriate friendships with men I
don't like that I'm going to be a little
bit jealous just as you would be jealous
of me if I were at inappropriate
boundaryless relationships with women
and I I don't like the idea that you've
got to post skimpy pictures of yourself
on the internet if you want to do that
you can go do that I won't be angry at
you but that's not that's not going to
work for me and I if we're going to move
towards something like marriage I I just
don't want my wife to be doing that and
I I don't want you to put yourself in
the
near occasion of sin and you know I
wouldn't do that myself either and I'm
not I'm not yelling at you I'm not being
angry I'm not threatening you in any way
you can go your own way it'll be totally
fine I'm just telling you that's that's
where I am
that's very reasonable
the only thing that he hasn't done is he
he should man up even further and say by
the way here's my this is my framework
not only for a relationship but for
marriage and then we can get married and
we can do what married couples do and we
can have kids and have a nice family and
it'll be a good life
totally totally right she responds to
all of this and she says I hope my ex
Joan hill has a daughter maybe she'll
turn him into a real feminist because
the fact that he calls himself a
feminist now is laughable and she that's
the one part she's right about Jonah
Hill is obviously not a feminist he
might pretend to be a feminist he might
dress up like a lib and use the language
of a lib but he's not he's not a
feminist he's a relatively normal guy
his ex-girlfriend obviously is a
feminist feminism is wrong
you should reject it men women anybody
in between that supposedly exists
nowadays reject it it's just the problem
with feminism is not that it gives women
too much power or whatever feminism
doesn't give women any power it deprives
women of their power it's just wrong the
problem with feminism
as is the problem with so many modern
ideologies
is that it posits a false anthropology a
false conception of human nature and so
when conservatives invade against
feminism it's not because we hate women
quite the Opposites because we love
women and it doesn't even come from any
sort of passion or any sort of personal
desire or anything like that it comes
from a rational
deduction and empirical observation of
human nature
and saying oh feminism says a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
feminism says that women and men are
pretty much the same and I just know
that that isn't true and so if you
pursue feminism
you're going to be miserable and unhappy
like Jonah Hill's ex-girlfriend and if
you don't pursue feminism and you pursue
normal life and you you recognize that
the Sexes are complementary rather than
indiscernible you're gonna have a better
life who seems to be doing better right
now Jonah Hill or the ex-girlfriend the
rest of my case boy what a great clip
that was make sure that you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel don't miss a single clip
or vid or interview or game or anything
see you next time